[Music]
table football was first patented by a
British inventor in 1923 it became
popular throughout Europe with leagues
forming by the 1950s a decade later an
American working in West Germany brought
the game to the US trade marking the
German word for it
foosball in France the game of foosball
is known as baby foot this company
produces ready-made as well as
custom-made tables like this one
featuring biker players production
begins at a foundry where workers melt
down bars of aluminum an injection
molding machine shoots the molten
aluminum into molds in the shape of
players a robot removes the casting from
the injection machine the mold yields
four players each one sporting the
manufacturer's name on the front of his
jersey a worker places each casting on a
press then with one strike separates the
four players and cuts off excess metal
a computer-guided machine drills a hole
in the center of each player through
which the rod will pass
then the machine threads a hole through
the players back for the screw that
secures the player to the rod another
machine saws a two millimeter gap in the
back to allow clearance for a screw
driver to tighten the player onto the
rod once ready the players move to the
foosball table factory where a worker
sprays on a base coat of white paint
once that dries workers continue
painting the players but now using an
airbrush they masked the players body to
paint only his head the company offers a
selection of skin tones then they mask
the player with another stencil covering
the skin and exposing the shirt and
socks
next they mask everything except the
players head and feet a player can be
brunette blonde or redhead they paint
the shoes black then the players eyes
and mouth manufacturers construct the
table out of solid beech a
computer-guided milling machine profiles
the wood components drills the required
holes and engraves the company name
workers then assemble the parts starting
with the four sides which connect with
bolted steel rods and glue
[Music]
after closing up the ends with wood
panels workers install wood support bars
which will reinforce the table and after
a goal direct the ball to the ball
return tray
the table now goes to the paint shop
where workers either stain the wood or
leave it natural for this model they
also spray red stain into the recess
stripes and logo
[Music]
all tables receive a finishing code of
transparent varnish to protect the wood
they install the sloped ball return
panel when a player scores the ball
rolls down the panel to an aluminum ball
return tray after sliding the plywood
table bottom into place workers turn the
table right-side up mount the aluminum
gollnitz
and the scoring units right behind them
then they lay the playing surface made
of green vinyl on pressed wood on top of
the wooden support bars would trim
around the perimeter holds the surface
in place a worker mounts the players for
each line onto a hollow stainless steel
rod using a template to space them
correctly he bolts each player to the
rod then attaches a rubber bumper to the
players at each end to prevent them from
slamming against the side walls he
inserts a narrower stainless steel rod
into the hollow bar to make it
telescopic after preparing eight rods of
players a worker installs them in the
table the telescoping handle end of the
rod has a spring-loaded bearing that
fits in a hole in the table he secures
it from the outside after bolting the
opposite end workers protect the top
edge of the table with a plastic trim
after threading plastic handles to the
telescopic end of the rods and mounting
the tables on four sturdy solid wood
legs this foosball table is ready for
kickoff
you